foreign
[Music]
well hello everyone thank you for
joining us for our program I'd like to
know uh we're glad that you're with us
and I've heard many good comments as
I've traveled and spoken in different
places where people have told me that of
all of our programming they appreciate
this q a program more than any other
we've thought about the possibility of
increasing the uh the time from a half
an hour to an hour a week because we
have a big pile of questions and we go
slowly we do our research and we try to
answer thoroughly and so please don't
get impatient with us if you sent us a
question and we haven't answered it yet
because it takes time to answer all of
the questions that we receive I want to
give you the email address where you can
send us your questions it'll be on the
screen TV at some tv.org once again TV
at some tv.org and I have with me David
Salazar uh who has joined us recently
and we're very very glad to have him
with us he's uh he loves research he
loves to answer questions and he has a
wonderful family thank you and we're
very glad that you're with us and we
hope that you will stay with us for a
very very long time thank you Pastor
it's a blessing for me and obviously for
my family to be part of this ministry
and to be able to provide our services
to to you of course and to the people
that are watching and we pray that the
Lord will allow us to continue to serve
him and you know the Lord has led us
here we'll continue to follow him amen
let's pray Father in heaven we come
before your throne with humility knowing
that your knowledge is infinite amen and
our knowledge is so limited and so we
plead for the help of your Holy Spirit
now as we attempt to answer these
questions with your word
we ask that those who are watching may
be blessed
and we also ask that you will instruct
us each day
in your will
in what you have in place for us today
and forever this we ask in the precious
name of Jesus amen amen
all right uh we have this very
interesting question that comes to us
from onesimus
name yeah that's uh first person I've
ever met who has that name other than
the onesimus of the Bible That's what
I'm saying yeah amazing and this comes
from Northampton Central Adventist
Church in the UK we received many many
questions from the UK of course we're
broadcasting in the entire UK our
programs right and so that's perhaps one
of the reasons why we received many
questions from there but uh what is the
question that they're asking well the
question is this
is it possible that a name that has been
written in the Book of Life can be
removed and later at some point be
regritten again in the book
so that is the question that on SMS has
for us pastor and I think that you know
you will help us understand this
question as it can be a question you
know very valid question a lot of people
may have the same question what happens
if I have committed some sort of hideous
sin or have rejected the Lord and after
I have been baptized or after I've been
part of the church I left the faith will
my name you know be out of book and can
I come back and be re-baptized or you
know can I name you be you know written
back in the book of life and I think
that this is a little bit of uh it's a
good question but it's also perhaps
based on certain misconceptions of what
it means that book of life and how our
name gets written in there
God uses the Eraser only once
once our name is written in the book of
life it remains there until our name
comes up in the Judgment correct and in
the Judgment if it is shown
that our profession of Christ was not
genuine
or we went astray from the Lord
then our name will be erased from The
Book of Life when our name comes up in
the Judgment correct but God doesn't
write our name and then you know when we
go away from the church that he uses the
Eraser and he raises it and then you
know when we're re-baptized he writes
our name again no in fact there's a
certain sense in which our names were
written in the Book of Life from the
foundation of the world
from the perspective of God right you
know our names are written when we're
actually baptized
but but for God
who sees everything as an eternal
present is already a done deal from
before this the foundation of the world
uh you know a similar uh idea is uh
Jesus is the Lamb of God slain from the
foundation of the world correct well we
know that from our perspective Jesus
died in the year 31. that's right but
from the perspective of God who lives in
an eternal present uh he didn't have to
wait until the year 31 for it to be
clearly in his mind because uh you know
he knew it was going to happen because
God knows the end from the beginning
it's kind of like uh in Genesis chapter
17 as well God says to Abram he says I
will make you a father of many nations
but then the very next verse he says I
have made you a father of many nations
yeah uh and Isaac hadn't even been born
yet right but God says I have made you
so the first verse verse 4 is Abraham's
perspective I will make you
but God who lives in an eternal present
everything is like it's happening right
now uh Abram who became Abraham was
already the father of many nations for
God it was a done deal the same is true
with the debate that Jesus had with the
Sadducees uh you know over the issue of
the Resurrection they kind of made fun
of him with the example of seven seven
marriages you know and and Jesus and
Jesus said something very interesting
um uh he said and I'm reading from Luke
Chapter 20 The End of uh towards the end
of the chapter he says even Moses showed
in the burning bush passage that the
dead are raised
now
how is the resurrection there in the
burning bush episode well God said to
Moses I am the god
of your of your fathers Abraham Isaac
and Jacob will Abraham Isaac and Jacob
were dead they'd been dead for centuries
but God doesn't say I was while they
were alive he says I am the god of
Abraham Isaac and Jacob and so basically
God is saying
even though for you Abraham Isaac and
did for me who live in the Eternal
presence and know for certain the
resurrection they are alive and it ends
the passage by saying uh even Moses
showed in the burning bush passage that
the dead are raised when he called the
Lord the god of Abraham the god of Isaac
and the god of Jacob for he is not the
god of the dead but of the living and
then it says
all live to him yes right not to us
we know that those that those three
individuals are dead but for God who
lives in an eternal present uh it's a
reality now and and Ellen White has this
statement in Desire of Ages page I'm
going to get to the issue of uh the the
name of the book of life in a moment but
we're setting the stage absolutely
faster go ahead and Desire of Ages 606
Ellen White is commenting on what I just
mentioned God counts the things that are
not as though they were
he sees the end from the beginning
and beholds the result of his work as
though were now accomplished the
precious dead from Adam down to the last
Saint who dies will hear the voice of
the Son of God and will come forth from
the grave to Immortal Life God will be
their God and they shall be his people
there will be a close and tender
relationship between God and the Risen
Saints
this condition
the condition of God being with the
Saints and the close relationship this
condition which is anticipated in his
purpose he beholds as if it were already
existing the Dead live unto him and
Ellen White has some interesting
statements uh manuscript releases Volume
14 pages 22-23
Ellen White wrote I Am means an eternal
presence
the past present and future are alike to
God absolutely not for us
the past present and future are
different for us but but she says the
past present and future are alike to God
he sees the most remote events of past
history and the far distant future
with as clear a vision as we do the
things that are transpiring daily
now let's go to the issue of when our
names are written
that's important Revelation 17 verse 8.
yes if you want to read that verse Revel
because I've talked too much already
a couple of verses to read but
when when were the names of the Lost not
written in the Book of Life
says there and the Beast that's that was
always was and he's not and shall Ascend
into the out of the bottomless pit and
go into Perdition and they that dwell on
the Earth shall wonder whose names were
not written in the Book of Life from the
foundation of the world
so you know speaking of the names of
those Britain that were not written from
the president of the world so they were
not written there from the foundation of
the world so what about the the names of
the saved
they must have been written from the
foundation of the world right so how do
we understand this well let me just
mention
that
um Ellen White clearly states that our
names are written in the Book of Life
when we're baptized
uh in God's Amazing Grace 143 She Wrote
the Father the Son and the Holy Ghost
Powers infinite and Mission receive
those who truly enter into Covenant
relations with God they are present at
every baptism to receive the candidates
who have renounced the world and have
received Christ into the soul Temple
so she's talking about baptism here
right these candidates have entered into
the family of God and their names are
inscribed in the Lamb's Book of Life
so when are their names written when
they when they're baptized however we
just noticed that they're The Book of
Life for the foundation of the world why
because God Lives an eternal presence
God did not have to wait until the
person was baptized to write his name in
The Book of Life from his perspective it
was already in the book of life but it
is empirically written there when the
person is baptized from our perspective
so there's two different perspectives
God's perspective our perspective Ellen
White didn't contradict the Bible of
course she's in perfect harmony with the
Bible now let me just read this
statement from great controversy it's
kind of long
but it gives an answer to the question
as the books of record are open in the
judgment
the lives of all who have believed on
Jesus come in review before God
so the pre investigative judgment is not
of all all people in the world it's only
those who have confessed at any time
professed professed Christ beginning
with those who first lived upon the
Earth
which would be the first to be judged of
course would be Adam
our Advocate presents the cases of each
successive generation and closes with
the living every name is mentioned every
case closely investigated names are
accepted names rejected
when any have sins remaining upon the
books of record
unrepented of and Unforgiven their names
will be blotted out of the Book of Life
and the record of their good deeds will
be erased from God's book from the book
of God's remembrance so when our names
erase from The Book of Life they are
erased when our name comes up in the
Judgment God doesn't write the name well
you know we went astray I gotta erase
the name I'll write the name again God
doesn't have to do that because God
knows the end from the beginning she
continues she provides now biblical
foundation for what she says the Lord
declared to Moses whosoever has sinned
against me him will I blood out of my
book and says the prophet Ezekiel when
the righteous turneth away from his
righteousness and committeth iniquity
all his righteousness
righteousness that he hath done shall
not be mentioned
all who have truly repented of sin and
by faith claimed the blood of Christ as
their atonian sacrifice have had
pardoned entered against their names in
The Book Of Heaven as they have become
partakers of the righteousness of Christ
and their characters are found to be in
harmony with the law of God their sins
will be blotted out and they themselves
will be accounted worthy of eternal life
the Lord declares now comes the biblical
foundation for what she said the Lord
declares by the prophet Isaiah I even I
am he that bloodeth out thy
transgressions for my own sake and will
not remember thy sins said Jesus he that
overcometh the same shall be clothed in
white raiment and I will not block out
his name out of the book of life but I
will confess his name before my father
and before his angels whosoever
therefore shall confess me before men
will him will I confess also before my
Father which is in heaven but whosoever
shall deny me before men him will I also
deny before my Father which is in heaven
so basically the answer to the question
is that God does not write any race
right any race write any race
our name once it's in the book of life
it remains there until our case comes up
in the Judgment if it's determined that
a profession was false then our name is
erase from the book of life amen well
said pastor I think you have really
covered everything I'm sorry no no
please by all means no actually it's
good today you explain this you know and
show Friends prayer prophecy and from
the Bible there is this verse that is
Reggie White mentioned there in Exodus
verse 33 but you know I just want to
bring something out to just kind of
reaffirm in verse 32
um actually 31 Moses speaks to the Lord
and he said to him and says Moses return
unto the Lord and said oh these people
have seen a great sin and have made them
gods of gold yet now if thou will
forgive their sin and if not let me I
pray thee out of thy book which thou has
written so here is Moses intercedent for
the people right and saying Lord please
forgive their sin
and and if if you will if if he can't
then take my name out of the book but
God kind of cannot do that and he says
to him and that's the answer and the
Lord said unto Moses whosoever had sin
against me him will I blot out of my
book so the Lord tells Moses
I am thankful that you have the love for
them that you want to even intercede and
plead in their behalf to the point that
you're willing to give up your life
eternal salvation for them but
this is very simple
I will only blot out those who have
sinned against me who will remain in sin
or their sins have not been forgiven or
have not been covered so it is very
clear from this from the Bible that the
when your name is written in the book
The Lord will only take it away when
that judgment is made as you mentioned
domestic judgment and
you have not
confess your sins and your sins have not
uh been forgiven and therefore that's
why your name is removed also with that
in mind in revelation 22 verse 19
is also an interesting warning from the
Lord uh and of course part of the sin
actually so it will be a sin but it says
and if any man shall take away from the
words of the book of this prophecy God
shall take away his part out of the book
of life and out of the holy city and
from the things which are written in
this book so you know also important to
know that when our names are are removed
is uh if our sins have not covered I
have not been forgiven have not been
covered by the blood of Christ we have
not confessed them
including a sin of removing or adding
from the spirit of you know from the
word of God so if you have committed
that sin and sometimes maybe that's what
some people have have argued you know
maybe my name was removed because I
denied this Bible or I was not talking
about it well it's clearly the sin that
remains that is not confessed what will
take away your name from The Book of
Life not necessarily the act of adding
or removing or adding Awards to the book
of the Bible until the time of probation
is closed so uh you know your
explanation I believe is very clear and
I think we have covered this uh very
well from this part of Prophecy any last
words pastor about that yeah you know
when you read from Exodus it jogs
something in my mind I can see but I
hadn't thought of before and I'll just
throw it out there I haven't checked the
original language yeah but uh it's
interesting that in
Exodus 32 verse 32
Moses says yet now if you will forgive
their sin but if not I pray blot me out
of your book
which you
have written
um
which gives the impression that the book
had already been written yes which
squares with what I had shared before of
course I have to look at the tense of
the verb in Hebrew we have to make sure
that but uh but you know this is uh at
least in the translation it's uh it's a
perfect tense something that happened in
the past that endures in the present
correct uh but uh I will do more
research on that and I encourage those
who are watching to do their own
research into the tense of the verb
there in Exodus 32 32. Amen to that so I
pray that you know we have answered the
question to anessimus from the word of
God from Spirit prophecy it and that he
can be assured that if if maybe he has
you know been LED astray and he may feel
that his name is not in the book of life
is nothing really happened that blotting
out of that name is only after the
corporation is close probation is done
and the judgment is finished
um all right let's continue to the next
question Pastor
um this is from somebody from South
Africa thank you glad Gladstone
and so it's wonderful to see that
they're writing us from all over the
world
the he has actually two questions I will
see if we can find uh squeeze them in
this time maybe one we'll figure that
out the question is says how the work
reconcile Genesis 3 Verse 6 the last
part that says she also gave her husband
with her and he ate
uh according to what he understands
there's a strong suggestion that
contrary to the pen of inspiration Eve
was with Adam at that moment that she
ate the forbidden fruit
so is it not possible that through Adam
was present just like the incident of
biolum and the donkey and indeed
more incidents as recorded only the
target Eva saw unheard so he's I guess
from the question he's asking that it
seems to him that Adam and Eve were
together when she took the fruit but
because Eve was the one interrupting
she's the one that is mentioned there
and he's trying to find out how does
that reconcile with his prayer prophecy
which says that she wander off by
herself well let's read the quotation
from the writings of Ellen White right
and then try and find uh reconciliation
yes between the biblical record and what
Ellen White States you know many people
think that Ellen White contradicts
herself until they study a little more
carefully and they'll discover that she
does not contradict herself you know
I'll give you a Biblical example how
Judas died you know if you read the
gospel of Matthew it says he committed
suicide yeah but if you read the book of
Acts it says that he fell headlong and
his belly split open and his his innards
came out yeah so how do you reconcile
those two the Bible contradicts itself
would be what many would say right Ellen
White reconciles it perfectly
she states that Judas was the largest of
the Apostles physically speaking and
there was a branch overhanging a cliff
and the rope that he intended to hang
himself with
uh let loose it broke
and he fell a long distance to the
ground and his belly exploded so he
intended to commit suicide but he fell
headlock there's no contradiction in the
Bible that's right you know people just
they're looking for excuses to not
believe and not trust in the Bible and
Ellen White made it very clear that Eve
but was by herself she wrote this the
Angels had cautioned Eve to be aware of
separating herself from her husband
while occupied in their daily labor in
the garden
with him she would be in less Danger
from Temptation that if than if she were
alone
but absorbed in her pleasing task she
unconsciously wandered from his side
on perceiving that she was alone she
felt an apprehension of danger but
dismissed her fears deciding that she
had sufficient wisdom and strength to
discern evil and to withstand it so
there's no doubt that that Eve was by
herself according to Ellen White Adam
and Eve were not there and Eve engaged
this conversation because first of all I
don't think that Adam being the head
would have would have
entertained the idea of her having a
dialogue with with the serpent serpent
um how do we reconcile this well it's
it's very simple uh if you go down to
Genesis chapter 3 3 and verse 12. I
think you have the explanation I have
that Pastor
um verse 12 says and the man said
the woman whom thou gave us to be with
me
she gave me the tree and I did eat
the woman that you gave to be with me
does that mean she was going to be with
him every second of every day
that's not necessarily the case no God
is saying the woman that I created
to as a mate for Adam right
so when it says with her with him
it it simply means that
um
he God created her to be with the man
right but it doesn't mean that she that
Adam was with her at the tree at that
particular moment furthermore if you
look here at the text verse six uh it
says there
she also gave to her husband with her
and he ate now it doesn't say when she
gave to her husband it says when she was
with him she gave uh to to uh you know
she gave to him but it doesn't mean that
it happened at the tree right it could
have happened when she was with him
after she ate from the tree another
thing interesting is that you know the
Apostle Paul speaks that Adam was not
deceived but the woman right you know
speaking on on the roles and and you
know in in the household and this is
important because it sort of gives you
or
confirms the fact that for her to be
deceived Adam was not near had Adam been
neared her they would have would have
been deceived at the same time but Adam
chose to eat of the tree of the fruit
even though he knew it was wrong he made
that mistake and that's why Adam is more
responsible
ultimately for the sin well Eve was
deceived and implying that she had to be
deceived when she was not around Adam so
I think the Bible sort of gives you that
of you know that confirmation that this
prophecy clearly states she was Alone
um yeah the text doesn't say right that
she gave
to Adam the fruit at the tree at the
moment it says that she gave the fruit
to him when he was with her that's right
so it's very possible that he wasn't
with her when she had the dialogue and
then when she was with him yes she gave
the fruit and that's the thing I think
that sometimes we have to be careful not
to imply more than what the text is
telling you and in this concept as we
can see is that she was the one that was
deceived was not with anybody else to
reconcile as a matter of fact in the
argument or the conversation Chicago the
serpent you don't see her asking or even
relaying to anybody else so it it really
I believe if you look at it you know in
in this context you can see that she was
alone the serpent deceived her when she
was alone yeah and you'll notice in
verse 6 at least in the new King James
version it says solo woman saw that the
tree was good for food and it was
pleasant to the eyes in a tree desirable
to make one wise she took of its fruit
and ate period
then after the period right it says uh
and I suspect that there might be an
athnak in Hebrew here which is the
equivalent of a period uh but I'll have
to check that out and so it says after
the period it says she also gave to her
husband she it doesn't say when
exactly she also gave to her husband
with her yeah it could have been with
her later on right right and he ate so
uh you know uh Ellen White I believe is
in perfect harmony with scripture praise
the Lord Pastor well we are very glad
that we have been able to spend this
time together asking answering his
questions we thank you once again for uh
sending us your questions we look
forward to answering more in the next
episode may God bless you and your
family as you study and to continue to
learn from the word of God and do this
uh practice of researching the Bible to
search the scriptures as you will find
the truth in them may God bless you see
you next time
thank you
[Music]